Maybe the worst part though,
was his laughter as he contorted himself,
to where his torso was now outstretched into the room with me,
and his arms were wildly waving in my direction.
Hello, and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta,
horror stories cooked to perfection with a
splash of red sauce. My name is CZ and I will
be your server this episode. Today’s episode
is a sequel to Creepy Clown School Lockdown,
which you can click or tap here to listen
to if you wish, but you don’t necessarily
have to watch them in order. This time we’re
moving up to high school. I know many of you
don’t look back at your high school years
too fondly, but I think today’s offering
will make you appreciate your experience a
little bit more. Let’s dig right in.
Fourth period Algebra was the most dreaded
part of my day. Not only do I hate math, but
it's the last morning class before lunch.
The schedule gets a little easier once I hit
that afternoon hump, but that hump is a big
one. I've never been good with math, and having
Mrs. Nelson, or as we call her, the Crypt
Keeper, was NOT making things easier this
semester. In fact, the only thing keeping
me afloat in that class was the fact that
my friends Chris was texting me the answers
from 2nd period.
It was a muggy afternoon towards the end of
the school year. As usual, Mrs. Nelson refused
to turn on the air conditioning. It was somehow
fitting to be broiling through my 4th period
hell.
We started the Thursday exam and The Crypt
Keeper plopped behind her desk in the front
corner of the room. Idiot. Cheating my way
though this would be easier that I thought.
I placed down a water bottle and slyly slid
my phone across my desk into the bottle's
shadow. Piece of cake. I opened up the text
conversation with Chris and began to transfer
the information onto the page. A. B. A. 24.3
repeating. I had to mix in a couple wrong
answers as well, just to make it believable.
Just then, I hear the unmistakable sound...
someone getting up from a chair. My eyes dart
up and see the old pile of bones rising to
her feet. Crap. I wondered if she suspected
something. She began to pace towards my desk.
Just my luck... I guess I'd have to act like
I was actually trying to solve the equations
until she sat back down. It was like reading
another language. I had no idea what I was
doing. That's when I noticed my phone buzz.
I should have turned off the vibration before
the test. I don't think it gave me away though.
Could have been anyone's phone from anyone's
pocket. But there was bad news. The vibration
started sliding my phone down the small incline
of the desk. It slowly slid away from the
safe cover of the water bottle. I glanced
up to the teacher. Her eyes were locked on
to me. The phone continued to slide down.
All I could do was hope that it stopped, or
that she'd turn away long enough for me to
slip the phone into my pocket. No such luck.
It fell off the desk and onto the floor. Trying
to play it off like it had fallen out of my
pocket, I reached down to grab the phone.
But a cold, bony hand grasped my wrist before
I could.
"Office. Now." Those were the only words that
came out of her mouth.
At least it was air-conditioned in the area
outside the Dean's office where I sat to await
my sentencing. The Dean's office was a smaller
room within the confines of the main office,
which basically connects all the offices of
the administration, who were supposedly all
out at lunch, so I'd have to wait for the
Dean to return before I would find out how
long I'd be spending in detention.
You can imagine my surprise when a fully costumed
circus clown dragging a big hammer, walked
into the room with me. That seemed odd. I
hadn't heard of any assemblies or anything
going on this week.
I'm not exactly sure when I had the realization
that something foul was up with this clown.
It wasn't when he grabbed a chair and shoved
it under the main door of the office to jam
it shut. I just saw it as more of a gag to
try to get me to crack a smile for some reason.
I guess when it started to get a bit uncomfortable
was when he dragged his hammer across the
desks in the middle of the office, knocking
over a bunch of stuff and making a mess, all
while locking eye contact with me and giggling
maniacally. Still, I just had no reason to
get too freaked out any further than bit of
nervous laughter. I mean, for all I knew the
school's admin could have been pranking each
other.
No, I don't think it was until I saw the clown
start talking to himself when the panic started
to set in.
"He-HA! Step right up and test your might!"
Then he swung the hammer in the air, high
over his head and freaking smashed it down
on the doorknob to the Principal's office!
The door was basically destroyed and swung
right open. Then the clown looked at me, dead
in the eyes and said:
"Ho-ho! Look's like we've got a winner!"
Then he trudged into the Principal's office.
I was frozen in fear at this point, not sure
if I should run for it and find someone, or
if I was on a hidden camera show or what the
hell was going on.
Meanwhile, the clown was rummaging around
in the Principal's office when I heard...
a loud crack from the school's intercom system.followed
by the sound of analog feedback. It went on
for a few seconds before being replaced by...
circus music, but it sounded creepy and messed
up. I think he had blown out the speaker on
the intercom. I also felt the air-conditioner
come to a halt, and if I wasn't mistaken,
it had been replaced with heat.
The clown side-shuffled out of the Principal's
office with his hammer slung over the shoulder
and the most evil-looking sinister grin. What
was shocking about his appearance was how
wide his smile spread. It looked like his
grin nearly stretched from ear to ear, and
I mean that literally. That, and the glowing
look in his eyes told me I needed to bolt,
right now! I sprang out of my chair just as
the clown screeched and charged at me! I slipped
into the Dean's office before he could get
to me, slammed the door and locked it. I knew
that wouldn't cover me for long though, so
I immediately went to the desk and tried to
push it in front of the door. It was much
heavier than it looked. I couldn't get the
thing to budge! The bookshelf would have to
do for now, but I knew I was only biding my
time.
I felt the crash of the hammer's impact attack
the door as I positioned the bookshelf. It
not only knocked the doorknob off, but smashed
the wood in in the area all around the doorknob,
letting in a beam of light from the outside.
That light soon became blotted out by the
clown's huge yellow smile staring at me through
the hole. He began to cackle. I didn't know
how long I had. I instinctively reached for
my phone to try to call for help... but my
I felt my heart plunge as I realized that
it had been confiscated by Mrs. Nelson. I
looked around the tiny office. There was a
phone on the desk -- a landline. I picked
it up and punched 9-1-1, but as soon as I
brought it to my ear, all I got was signal.
The line had somehow been disconnected.
With no window in the room, I had no means
of escape. And with the main office door barricaded,
I was trapped in here with this.... this maniac.
Just then I realized he was no longer staring
through the hole. He was going to try to ram
it in again. I felt my eyes well up with tears
as I started to realize all the possibilities
of what he might do to me. With one last ditch
effort, I grunted and pushed the Dean's desk
as hard as I could, and managed to tip it
over and send it slamming to the ground! The
picture of the Dean's daughter shattered on
the floor, but there was no time to worry
about the repercussions of that now. The door
was starting to open and I was able to drive
the desk just far enough to stop the clown
from getting in!
I struggled to push the desk for a few moments
more, and it seemed like we were at a stalemate.
Then it seemed like the he had stopped pushing.the
sound of the circus music abruptly stopped,
and as far as I could tell like the clown
had given up. Then, out of nowhere, through
the partially open and partially busted door,
the clown lodged himself in the opening and
tried to squeeze himself through. I screamed
when I saw the circus makeup melting off his
face like some kind of nightmarish Munch painting.
His once round puffy red wig was now drenched
in sweat and stuck to his face in a series
of dark red strands.Maybe the worst part through,
was his laughter as he contorted himself to
where his torso was outstretched into the
room with me and his arms wildly waved in
my direction.
Instinctively, I jumped back, which was a
bad idea, because he was then able to retract
back to the other side of what was left of
the door and slowly but surely force it open
in my direction. At this point he'd surely
get in. All I could do was prepare myself
to fight a battle I knew I could not win.
Then... out of nowhere, his progress just
stopped... This time I didn't let down my
guard. I stood on high alert when I noticed
some banging around in the background. Someone
was trying to get into the office! I suddenly
could see the light at the end of the tunnel
and hoped I might be saved.
The main office door was kicked down and the
voice of the school police officer yelled
out!
"Freeze! Get your hands in the air!" I have
to admit, it didn't sound very convincing
given that I could hear the tremble in his
voice. But I was at least somewhat comforted
knowing he'd be armed.
I called out for help and the officer rushed
to my aid. The strange part was, the clown
was nowhere to be found. I explained that
he had smashed in this door moments before,
but in searching the entire office, we couldn't
figure out how he had gotten away.
All in fact, there were only two pieces of
evidence that ended up being found. One was
a rubber clown nose left clamped on the microphone
in the Principal's office that was hooked
up the school's PA system. The other was a
knot of red hair from the clown's wig. I would
later find out that they ran tests on it and
discovered that it was real human hair. It
belonged to this guy Bronson, who was currently
in prison serving a 15 year sentence. There
was no way he had escaped, so the appearance
of his DNA only added to the mystery...
I wish I could say it ended there... with
me getting out of my punishment on account
of the traumatic experience, but there was
one more haunting thing that happened.
While it was true I didn't have to serve my
detention, I think it's safe to say that I
learned my lesson, and I was never going to
cheat on another test again, or do anything
that might get my phone confiscated for that
matter. I was able to scratch by and pass
math class with a D. My parents weren't happy
about it, but again, I got a little sympathy
after having nearly become the jester's afternoon
snack or whatever.
So summer came and I was free for a couple
more months. Chris and I were skateboarding
on the street toward 7/11 and I heard a strange
sound and stopped.
"What's wrong?" Chris asked me. I held up
an index finger. I listened for a moment,
and I was sure I could make out the sound
of... the same circus music from that day
in the office. I looked up to find the car
it was coming from, a beat up red bug, no
license plate. My eyes met with the driver's:
it was the same very same clown from before,
again with the makeup melted down off his
face onto his collar in a most disturbing
manner. He rolled up the window.
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total today is $24.33 but if you like
this video right now, I'll waive that fee
and give you everything you just listened
to: absolutely free. This episode's score
was done by the talented OST Maker. And the
end theme you're hearing now is Naoya Sakamata's
rendition of Beethoven's Moonlight Sonata.
Head into the comments and let me know any
other stories you'd like to see get a sequel.
Every like and comment helps out the channel,
but if you want to float too, you'll have
to pick up one of these shirts from the merch
store. Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for
new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
till it says all notifications, and I'll see
you in the next one. Assuming we both survive